[Music]
welcome back to the dink here we go
this episode's brought to you by this
skin guys get yourself filled in on all
the latest news in a very easy to read
format with the skin go to th e sk IMM
comm / genitally and it's free just
click Subscribe enter your email you're
good honey book guys if you're a
freelancer or a photographer or if
you're a small business owner and you
don't know how to deal with all the
business side of things and you're like
man this is all really stupid I just
wanted to pursue my hobby
honey books for you they take care of
all sorts of what what business standing
here oh they wanna okay how they take
care of all sorts of your business
dealings when you know when you may not
be equipped for all of that go to a
honey book HOA any ybo ok.com promo code
Jen and Julian check it out and get 50%
of your first year and it applies
whether you're doing annual or monthly
payments and also guys a new sponsor
this week I believe a new sponsor calm
if you're struggling to sleep calm is
the number one app for sleep so check it
out you guys get 20% off comm premium
subscription at calm CA LM calm /gen and
julian seize the day so if you want to
seize the day sleep tonight go to calm
down calm / enjoy and click the link
down below check it out it's actually
cool yeah thank you sponsor sleep is
very very important yeah I can't use
some I I could be using calm more i
competing marbles on the other hand does
not need come ever these guys sleep so
much i was thinking about the other day
because when were like we walk them we
hang out with them we do our thing but
when we're like doing whether it's work
or we're hanging out watching TV gaming
you're sleeping they're sleeping and
then they go from hours and hours of
that alright well time to go to bed and
then they sleep what so many hours so
many hours
the thing is though too is that like
the door's always open they can always
go outside and don't run around like
they always have an option to do
something and they always do we do this
lazy dog shoes to sleep
is that how dogs are like everywhere
what are you doing she really does not
want to sit in her bed why it's a very
comfortable big furry bed that we spent
probably too much money on and also
burned the side of I didn't bring this
up we together as a unit burned the side
of that net mm-hmm
there was a alleged fireplace in our
last house
the distance between the bed and the
fireplace no one ever saw it
we actually it son confirmed the
distance and now side of it is yellow
and it was brown before we actually
should have someone check that out do
you think that's safe is there a
chemical reaction because I know it
wasn't I know it wasn't the fire because
it couldn't have been it was did you
bleach the hair of that bleached and he
bleached the hair of it because it has
like long hair you know I love just like
did you take that to ratchet leach and
dark fabrics it looks good I mean it
looks sort of like frosted tips of the
bed can we show them can you is anyone
in it I feel like we should show them I
know hey babe could you grab that bed
real quick no no okay I'll describe it
do you not want it's a very Brown bed
okay with the hair that's like about
this long it's like almost like a shag
carpet but it's like you know furry and
brown looks kind of like a bears laying
down there and then on the top of it
it's gold thank you you're welcome
how was how was that storytelling it was
really good really I was gonna wear my
computer glasses on the podcast but I
realized that when I put these on you
all you see is the light yeah my glasses
do that too because I have the computer
glasses thing for this oh no sorry y'all
we have reflections in our glass wearing
my podcast cross nice podcast glasses
glasses
honestly podcast glasses okay it's an
invention if you put them on and then
all of a sudden you're all
she jumped all the way up to the table
how did you do that that was very high
I'm telling you she really wants to sit
with you give him the podcast full ass
right now
like full ass where this goes on YouTube
and iTunes and Spotify click the links
below okay she wants this is what she
wants Father's Day she wants to be a
okay five years old meanwhile Kermit
left I don't know where he went
he's probably eating something
downstairs Bunny's not here either they
didn't want to join and say hey Kermit
did we lock him outside no
wasn't there a podcast where we realized
peach was outside like mid podcast
probably probably years ago any old
house happy birthday remember that she's
five I was just about to say something
cool what was they by the same I don't
know 40 stuff I was saying something
podcast glass Oh podcast glasses great
idea so you put them on and then you're
qualified to talk about any subject on a
podcast all you need is the podcast
glasses and then you're good you have
all the degrees and Wow
I thought you were gonna say that when
you put them on it blew mileage may vary
it's when you put them on it blasts a
podcast out other people like the audio
of it they're just speakers like where
are the speakers and they built into the
rims yeah it's just someone shopping at
you it's just one podcast and it's a
very aggressive one yeah those are we
have two versions of podcast glasses let
us know which one you want my version is
$8,000 but it comes with all the
credentials you need all right Julian
what are we doing today
I thought we were talking about great
ideas but I would get some move on to a
Q&A we have a curate we're doing a QA
Marisa I did it for us our wonderful
twitch mod Marisa took the time to
actually she helped us because she helps
run the Instagram so you guys sent in
questions to our Instagram and we have
what we have a 4:20
so we have 20 questions for both of us
then we have five for each of us yeah
and I've looked over most of these but
some of them I haven't looked over
should we just get right into it yeah
okay number one how long did it take you
to pick a major in college do you know
what you wanted to do did you know what
you wanted to do at the time
no when I was a freshman my advisor and
my mom and anyone that was like helping
me make decisions I was undecided or I
didn't like apply to a certain school
for a certain program or anything like
that I just went to the school that I
wanted to go to because it was in Boston
and that was the criteria for me picking
the college but I certainly did not know
what I wanted to study so my freshman
year I took one class in communications
in one class in psychology which is sort
of the two that I was back and forth
between and I decided that I hated my
communications class what was
communications like like what do you do
the the class that I took was called
mass communications which to be honest I
got an A in the class but like I really
just didn't want to be there yeah I
didn't the subject was not interesting
to me like most of those people were you
know PR majors and you know all the
media stuff like I don't know there
there was a small like film area of the
school that I went to but like none of
it was interesting to me it was just
like media for sure not new media
because that wasn't a thing so yeah and
it just genuinely bored me and so like
Communications is sort of like the
bridging of media and the PR right so
it's like is that like what is I
actually don't even know the answer to
what Communications is technically
referring to it wouldn't usually do I
and I took a whole class in it no idea
couldn't [ __ ] tell you okay she's
like if you're a comm major you you know
how to communicate well no it's more
like magazines newspapers television so
media
yeah it's called media well it was
called communications I'll talk to him
okay so you were you were going to
Communications and sweat you decided
switch are you you were thinking about
both wait so you took a class in
communications yeah well then you
decided psychology yeah I took a psych
class and I took any one communications
class that I could get in rather to my
schedule yeah and I hated that class and
everyone and it was pretty obnoxious
fair enough although to be fair but like
in the nicest way possible psych 101
classes can also be very obnoxious
because some people use it as a when
they start learning about things they're
like I know about this because it
happened to me and you're like okay you
know I really respect you and the other
thing that you've been through my friend
but educational classroom I'm just
trying to learn the basics here you know
that was a very lengthy story you told
about your brother but you know we only
have 45 minutes here we have a lot of
material to cover but I respect you and
care about you it's like studying
kinesiology and being like no I broke my
leg I know I'm not gonna study this part
I know all of this I know how this feels
and looks but yeah I really that's how I
paid so my sophomore year I decided that
I was a psych major for me I went in I
was gonna be a business major because I
was like really more focused on baseball
and then when baseball stopped being in
my life I was like I hate this I hate
business I didn't want to be in any of
the classes I was in I wasn't enjoying
there was no like there was no bit of me
that was like grabbed by the material
yeah I'm just kind of showing up then I
pretty sure the paper was first then I
decided to write for the school paper
I really enjoyed that sounds like maybe
I should do writing that was like I
don't think writing is my thing
I like writing but I don't think that's
what I want the entirety of my college
you know experience to be around based
around so I I was writing for the school
paper I was doing sports game like I was
writing for the sports section and then
I decided let's try I think it was
actually one of my GE classes was like a
broadcast journalism class like an intro
to something
it was like okay this is interesting you
know you need to work with cameras learn
about lighting audio some programs in
the news I was like okay that's what
I'll do so I decided to be television
broadcast journalism with some what it
wasn't technically a minor but it was
like somewhat of a minor in journalism
like written journalism because I took a
lot of classes on that and spent like
two and a half years in the paper
writing for the paper so that was it
yeah I just kind of found a class and I
was like this is more interesting than
what my major is some of us which yeah
and I think that the gist of the
question is like you know how long did
it take you to figure out what you
wanted to study and it's like how did
you get there and from my experience and
you know from knowing a lot of people in
college it's sort of like it's totally
fine to be undecided and it's totally
fine to switch but I think the best way
to get to where you want to go is to
just take a class or two it's an
elective or anything you can sort of
squeeze in and figure out what class is
really interesting to you and I know
that school isn't for everyone so like
if nothing's interesting to you that
that's totally fine too but like for me
was I'm good at math and science and
like not I knew that I wasn't gonna get
a Bachelor of Arts you know I knew I was
gonna get a Bachelor of Science yeah
because it's just what I'm good at and
something that goes into my brain he
wasn't a be able know I was not a v8
imma be a boy yes girl it's better
science but yeah it's just taking a
class or two and figuring out something
that's interesting to you because you
know once I you have some exposure
obviously to some of the stuff you can
study in college or else I don't know
mm-hmm you've surprised you in college
or like yeah you have some exposure but
taking a class and really going into it
and being like oh this is really
interesting and I could take a there's
so much more I'd love to learn about
this and it's a cool feeling because I
think when I that first happened to me I
wasn't expecting to ever feel that way
about a class yeah well if you're in
love is
in your like this wasn't terribly
interesting it feels like well none of
this is terribly interesting what am i
doing I just want to play yeah which is
fine to totally second question is do
you regret getting a degree since you
don't use it for your current job no no
no no no no yeah I mean I've talked
about that plenty ever it's one of the
most important experiences socially
whole like the whole thing among
emotionally mentally physically
spiritually that I have gone through so
I don't I don't regret one second of
that yeah and like the second part of
the question is even though you don't
use it for a current job and I feel like
that comes up a lot like do you use your
degree for your job and that comes up
for probably a lot of people who work in
new media because there's not a lot of
like I mean now they're starting to pop
up but like degrees in new media or
whatever you're kind of studying the old
media then you get into the real world
and it's not that but I would argue that
my degree helped me more in life than my
job just like in life just the
experience of going to college made me
in outside of work just the human in
society a better more equipped person
yeah I think we're Millennials in that
you know our parents were like go to
college this is a way for you to get a
you know career an entry-level job and
be competitive in the workforce that you
can have a that path to life you know
and for our parents it was like not as
expensive you know still the same time
commitment and then after they were done
they were guaranteed a well-paying job
as opposed to if they had not gone to
college
whereas Millennials spend way more money
on college are guaranteed absolutely
[ __ ] nothing then they get out and
then a lot of them end up changing
fields or figuring out something else
where they can make money or do anything
and I think that were true Millennials
and that we both got degrees and
something that we are not currently in
theory working in our fields you know
but that that experience to invest that
time into your education and how to be
an adult yeah all of that you know you
use those skills every day I would I
would be horribly ill-equipped equipped
to do my current job
if I didn't have those experiences where
you know just general time management
for decades of my life time management
and discipline like anyone can look at
you and be like you've been doing this
for so long and you're still very
successful at everything that you do and
I wonder where that came from oh you
finished graduate school in luckier Kerr
like - yeah I mean that's not why but
it's no but it like makes sense do you
think about that and you're like okay
the discipline to do a kind of makes
more sense to how you have the
discipline to do B which is your career
and it's just me speaking personally
it's not that's just my experience
that's what the podcast is it's all
about us dude all about only our
experiences sorry alright what else you
guys suggestions for eating vegan at
restaurants oh okay first depends where
you are
second depends how hungry are you good
preface okay then do you like potatoes
yeah I would say potatoes are your best
friend beans rice be careful because a
lot of them are especially at Mexican
restaurants their season their
obsessions chicken stock yep I don't
know it's it's sometimes it sucks
sometimes just understand that you're
probably not gonna get like what like
food they're like you're not gonna say
she ate yourself you're just gonna like
be a good sport and not draw attention
to yourself and you know get through it
some days you you might have a plate
full of sides you know it's gonna be
okay I went to Spago for a meeting wore
a t-shirt and a hat and got made fun of
for it but I probably deserved it cuz
it's a very fancy restaurant I didn't
know that I was like I gotta go to a
lunch meeting okay
I'm gonna wear lunch stuff yeah anyway
that's not the point the point is they
only have like me and seafood so I
ordered a side of peppers and a side of
mushrooms and that was my lunch that's
sometimes what it's gonna be that's my
advice sometimes it's gonna be peppers
and mushrooms or pasta or something like
that but usually if if you if there's
something on the menu that you feel like
you could ask you know a salad or a
pasta dish or
thing if well for you it's harder it's
gluten-free but if you're like could I
possibly do this with no egg and you
know none of this on top I don't I'm
vegan any animal products is there or if
you know if you're at a nicer restaurant
and you're like can this [ __ ] chef
make me anything possibly yeah where our
default is usually like I just get a big
plate of fries yeah I mean ideally
you'll have you'll be at a restaurant
where they're willing to work with you
and a lot of restaurants nowadays are
mindful of dietary restrictions totally
so use that you know but yeah sometimes
it's just gonna be sometimes it's just
being that person that's like can I
please have this with no X Y & Z yeah
and then when then the whole entire
conversation becomes about you and your
diet and you know it's fine just yeah
when they start talking about they want
to talk about your diet just talk about
how your farts are and they'll be like
okay let's talk about something okay
what what if they want to bring dude if
your diet becomes the topic of
conversation and you're like I don't
want this to be the type of conversation
you're like how long you been v um like
a year but when I first started my farts
were crazy exactly and then they're
gonna be like let's talk about sports
how is that helpful advice all I'm
saying is if you don't want the
conversation be about you and didn't
steer em away just get behind the wheel
make a couple right turns and steer them
away steer them away
why do you shop vegan for other products
ie household stuff makeup etc I really
try yeah I mean I try my skincare and
like a lot of my makeup at this point is
like vegan and cruelty free because they
there are so many options and it's just
not quite the same space that it was
like ten years ago
I feel like you can get really cool fun
products that are vegan and cruelty free
and if that exists for me to get I would
love to purchase that over something
that's not yeah and um I would say that
I try my my best but that this I don't
know this might be controversial but
like there's some hypocrisy sometimes in
veganism like we don't eat animal
products but we feed our dogs animal
every day you know and for
me personally I try 100% of the time to
not consume animal products you don't
try you do do yeah and like everything
else I try my very best while knowing
that sometimes like you have to make a
compromise it might be unavoidable we
have dogs it's difficult we can't have
dogs if we're not willing to feed them
their diet you know I think I think
that's that's the kind of point here
it's like well if we're if we're taking
it to the next level I think it's too
far because then you're endangering or
putting someone else at risk well yeah I
mean if you're not willing to feed an
animal their diet their like actual diet
like what they're actually supposed and
well there's someone that I really like
on YouTube the unnatural vegan she's so
like we do sound us out recently
yeah she's ridiculously practical and
logical and she talks about a lot of
stuff like that you know that it's in a
perfect world yes we wouldn't use animal
products for anything or animals for
anything sometimes it's just like we
live in a house I'm sure a lot of
habitats for em no animals we're here
before yes you know into those habitats
can you really like I don't know there's
just a lot of stuff I try my very best
as the answer but for me my main focus
is not consuming any animal products and
for the rest of it is like am I gonna
scream and cry and freak the [ __ ] out
about everything in the world I try my
best because I feel like I would just
get weight I would lose my mind and just
live off grade in a jungle somewhere
because everything is a lot but yeah I
try my very best
especially with makeup beauty products
that kind of stuff yeah further I'm I'm
the same I mean like when it comes to
shoes and materials and things like that
I mean I'm very very very mindful trying
my best to never purchase something that
you know has been used has taken animal
products to make or whatever but yeah
again it's like you have to be practical
you have to think of like other things
besides just like being by the book and
being very strict like in this case it
would be like our dogs for our quality
of life like
where do you live if you actually want
to be a vegan exactly you live in the
forest like a caveman no he lives in a
cave that's yep good answer though if
you could live anywhere other than la
where would it be well considering we're
going 100% vegan I'm gonna go live in a
tree somewhere I would still probably
say Austin Austin yeah realistically I
think I would too yeah it's been my like
I'll see what I see you place you know I
agree
yeah maybe Montana but that's a very
different life very different life but I
would people will try visiting first ok
no ok I'll pack the stuff all right cool
I'll pack the stuff like our whole laps
put it in the car it's not gonna fit
my got a shrinking machine is this
question says is now a good time for a
sec yeah it actually is and right now
guys if you're getting ready to go to
bed or you're struggling to sleep and
you need to wake up fresh and energized
for something the next day that was
actually on there yeah somewhere
actually I think risk guys calm is a
great app if you struggle with sleep ok
one in three people don't get enough
sleep and lack of sleep can negatively
negatively affect your ability to learn
solve problems make decision and overall
thrive as a human being trust me I know
I've deprived myself in sleep many many
nights and I've felt all of the
repercussions and it's not fun so don't
go in the App Store download calm we're
going to calm CA LM calm / Jenna Julian
you get 25% off comm premium which is
their premium subscription and they give
you tools like soundscapes
and like a bunch of sleep stories things
that help you kind of drift off you know
it brings you into the sleepy dreamy
world and they do it a really nice
effective way narrated often times are
people with soothing voices like Jerome
Flynn from Game of Thrones things like
that just things that you wouldn't
exactly think of but it's worth giving a
shot if you struggle with falling asleep
so check it out go to comm or hit the
link down below and get some sleep also
guys the skin is an incredible tool
to educate yourself on the world's
current events and the things that are
going on that you might not get all the
facts from other sources like social
media this scheme is a newsletter you
enter your email click subscribe it's th
es ki mm comm slash annejulien you
should go there and enter your email
it's easy it's a really great service I
mean it's a very beautifully compact and
easy to read newsletter in the morning
that you get every day and coffee in the
skin so check it out and right now you
enter for a $250 Visa gift card
it's completely free there's nothing
required of you so just enter your email
click Subscribe check it out see how you
like it
also guys honey book if you're a
freelancer photographer graphic designer
just have a small business you need help
with invoices and documents and
brochures and calendar management and
East signatures all that stuff that
you're like I don't know how to do that
I don't know how they were supposed to
learn how to do that I'm an artist
that's a very business honey bug is
there to help you their payment is
flexible use the Jenna Julian code you
get 50% off monthly or annually that's
$20 a month or $200 for a whole year of
organization over 75,000 for
photographers designers event
professionals and just solo
entrepreneurs of all other kinds have
used honey book and right now you can
check it out it is a really great tool
if you're struggling with the business
side of things which i think a lot is a
very common problem from people who
start their own yeah situation they're
like okay now I need to hit this person
with an invoice I don't know how to even
do that because I did I did that and it
was really hard the process was really
shitty I wish I had a honey book at the
time so I hit the link down below or
check it out
Thank You sponding sponsors thank you
for letting me talk about sponsors guys
I appreciate you what notes you've
gotten there
I have Teta did the new IRS so the
photos is very different okay here we go
YUM and fun what's the biggest obstacle
bunny has overcome this far I'd still
say the stairs yeah she came all the way
up yep she's started coming all the way
up because I know in your video that you
posted her birthday yeah she was going
down the stairs she so goes all the way
down the stairs without a problem
she comes out of her crate and of
sensors but only recently we literally
tried
should we go she would saw at the bottom
of the stairs and she would go up the
first half and then stand on the landing
and then that's when we would have to do
her paws or carry her depending how
exhausted you are and it was like an
intimidation thing she didn't like the
second because going up that means we
gear up stairs now the first half of the
stairs easy yeah so we tried to just go
get it make it a big deal so they were
going we're going to babe going upstairs
and everybody come obviously these guys
get all very excited yeah and just see
what she does yeah and she came you know
about 15 minutes later we're just up
there came all just walking in the room
and I was like oh my god you did it
yeah one thing Jenna had a good idea for
which herself the law is at night once
she's upstairs like not letting her in
her crate for like 10 minutes letting
her just explore the room so she can
really familiarize herself and feel
comfortable with her space outside of
her crate that definitely helped for the
mornings that made it so in the morning
she's totally fine coming out right out
of her crate and downstairs but yeah you
used to sort of sit in there and bark
and like be a little nervous to come out
when we were trying to figure out what
that was yeah and I think that it's just
she's never spent time up there she
never spends time upstairs unless she's
in here yes not even right now she's
downstairs because we were doing the
thing we were like okay we're going
upstairs if you want to come with us you
can and she doesn't have to whereas
before in the podcast we would help her
up this year yeah I think one podcast
where she just kind of followed us and
we were like wow that was amazing but
then the last couple we had been having
to help because it's daytime she's like
why would I go upstairs in the data it's
hard though I mean she's progressed in a
lot of areas and then regressed in a lot
of areas like they're still we're still
dealing with resource guarding yeah even
though you know for like a month she was
like I'm done with this fam and then
she's like just kidding I'm not get away
from me growl snap snarl whenever she
has a toy or a toy so I mean there's
still stuff that we were working on and
she's doing really good in some places
but I would say her coming all the way
up the stairs by herself is just really
cool yeah for sure I would agree what is
the past tense of ye yo or heated
we did see it although yote is pretty
dope yeah it's funny but it's definitely
eated why are you coughing on me he just
needed a cop on you what is it what's
the most rebellious thing you did as a
teen and got caught for [ __ ] sneaking
out where like I was with my friend and
a couple of boys first of all that she
liked snuck out and came over to her
house when we were having a sleepover
and then her parents found out and then
my parents went oh [ __ ] he had a whole
[ __ ] scheme yeah I mean I was sort of
like the I did passive bad [ __ ] like I
wasn't the one ringleader I was never
the ringleader I was never the one that
was like guys let's do this bad thing
yeah I was always like okay okay I won't
tell me no way one time right away from
home I felt so annoyed at my mom and
brother I remember I think I felt like
they were teaming up on me it was like I
hate this running away so I ran away I
went right to my friend Andrew's house I
literally I think I walked there and it
wasn't close I probably spent like 3540
minutes walking then when I got there I
well I mean I would I think I had might
have been texting him I think I was
texting him and I was like hey I'm out
of her own yeah I think it was like
freshman year in high school no one's
ever gonna be able to find you at your
best friend's house who you been texting
for the last half hour I show up and as
soon as I get there his mom's like I
can't stay here I got to talk to your
mom so but I stayed there for a little
bit and hung out and then I went back
home I was like see that's what happens
now I'm gone I'm gone you team up on me
I'm out I'm going to Andres don't quite
video games okay man that that reminded
me that I wasn't a teen but me and my
like childhood best friend we used to
love to do everything together and one
of our favorite games to play was let's
intentionally get lost in the store with
either of our moms
I remember her like what is wrong with
you girls and we're like hiding in a
rack of clothes like under it's like
dude she can't find us dude she's
[ __ ] worried look at it she's
freaking out and then you hear your name
over the loudspeaker they're like well
Jenna please report to the customer
service desk your mother is looking for
you and I'm like oh [ __ ] game's over
yeah it's always game over when they go
to the the announcer in the store we did
that a couple times and then parents be
like where are they why do kids do this
and kids be like this is an activity
I don't know as an adult I'm like how
terrifying like what a mean awful that
like that's really did a viable base oh
that's just good well because you've
been a child and you've lost your mom in
this store before I knew yes sobbing yes
but like as an adult bigger Bank you
can't just like stand there and sob and
scream and cry and be like I can't find
my child I mean I didn't figure it out
that's basically the emotion so but my
mother and her mother through cuz it was
fun yeah but we didn't do it a lot I
just remember a couple of times being
like we're doing it that's pretty funny
we lost we lost we did parents learnt so
much [ __ ] trouble whose mom's gonna
cry first isn't mine um what was your
nickname growing up I think so hi mommy
I just heard on the stairs I would be
very impressed I know any girl my
parents are so call me but or not okay
that's cute but although my mom also I
was too young to remember but my mom
would call me BJ for baby Jenna but I'm
like glad nobody call me BJ baby that's
a really cute yeah girl you BJ from now
on should we call my brother Biff your
mom called your brother path yeah funny
Nick there she be driving she go I'm
just gonna BIP into this store oh yeah
she's gonna
she just comes over comes up with verbs
makes him up
Julie Bop was what my dad and grandpa
called me Julie my grandpa called me
Julie oh wow
Julie boy my dad call me Julie BOP and
my friends you ready for this
call me so Lee that was shut up headshot
that was my xbox gamertag oh my where my
name with three actually technically
still one of my emails right now and
none of y'all gonna [ __ ] guess it but
it's solely something threes always that
was it
do you sleep with the top sheet yes but
Julian always kicks it off this was like
I would say like three or four years ago
i sat you down and I was like stop doing
that to the flat sheet stop it or I'm
not gonna sleep next to you listen to me
boy okay this is an important part of
the bed you can't just like kick it off
and not have it don't look at me like
that and then I'd be like I'm gonna try
really hard to learn how to act while
I'm asleep
okay got it he used to kick it off and
it would just be like in a crumpled at
the bar I'm in like a neat sleeper like
I love when the beds made like if I make
a bed and then I alone sleep in it I can
just sort of like when I wake up in the
morning just move the blanket and then
it's already made again like I don't
it's usually kicked off at the bottom of
our bed somewhere learning to sleep you
just pull that hair out of his mouth
just pull the whole hair I thought it
was on my leg like I was just gonna move
it it was in his mouth it was in his
mouth and he just looked at me I was
like oh you are nasty God he never
ceases to amaze me with his nastiness
sorry anyways that didn't happen the
learning curve of sleeping with another
person regularly as an adult was
difficult for me but I've got I've come
very far I think yeah you see my only
film or document like your cheat meals
what do you eat on a normal day it's
good question yeah I mean a normal I
know there's like I like watching videos
what I either people like eating normal
food you know but I think for you sort
of like I would just want to make
something exciting I wouldn't usually
make yeah but I'd say for a typical day
I mean when we're not ordering takeout
being naughty it's like smoothie for
breakfast a salad for lunch and then
we'll make something for dinner we've
shared a lot of our dinner recipes on
the stream like the shepherd's pie the
pastas we do a lot of gelato the chili
pad thai we can't honestly kind of have
like six recipes and then we just rotate
through them yeah or like sometimes
seasonally - it's like we'll make a nice
kill Caesar salad with some actual corn
and then Julian will eat the corn
I'll eat Julian's corn because he'll be
like alright fine you can have corn in
the Natalie I don't want it to point on
the coordinate point on the coin bone
corn but instead of the corn bone it's a
hot dog although I don't not like a big
breakfast either but like I do really
like two pieces of toast with chilies on
it like chili beans
yeah chili toast so I you take like
kidney beans or whatever beans you like
with a little crushed tomato and do
chili seasoning and you just let that
cook down and you put that on toast I'm
gonna make a video what I eat a day was
like vegan and title and then just eat
like jello every meal oh my god why did
you do that I don't know I don't think
I've ever seen or what I eat that's just
jello for every meal is it vegan jello
who knows it's for every meal what the
hell Julian yeah it's gotta be vegan Joe
maybe just con candy instead okay what's
your favorite part about what I eat in a
day eating but I just think jello before
using utensil just you just slurp it up
cut the breakfast lunch sometimes
sometimes when I wake up overnight and I
need a snack I go really light um go
down in the fridge slurp it that's a
[ __ ] post Julian yeah you know let's see
what your favorite part about being an
influencer does it ever hit you the
amount of impact you have over people I
don't know
yes I think I don't I said my favorite
part is like just when you go somewhere
and someone's like tell you dogs I said
what's up yeah thank you for just nice
it's really nice that's my favorite part
yeah um I don't know I try not to think
about yeah the rest of it yeah it gets a
little overwhelming it does one of my
favorite things has been like in twitch
I'm hanging out live and there's a chat
room full of people saying things having
conversations with me and making
everyone laugh and making everyone laugh
but also just like you know I'm having
common I'm having really cool
conversations with people who are very
nice and pleasant and smart and funny
that I normally wouldn't have been able
to have you don't II mean if I wasn't an
influencer I didn't have people watching
me I wouldn't have that opportunity to
hang out with so many cool people it's
pretty cool like just by going live
that's such a cool thing like often
times I'll find myself be like oh this
is really fun conversation we're having
her like something cool we're talking
about I'm like damn that's cool you know
I get to talk to you guys engage that
conversation what's the best gift you've
ever received not from each other huh
best gift you've ever received when I
was a kid I got a Lion King electric
toothbrush and I wanted so bad and I
feel like I waited an eternity for
Christmas to come I put it on my
Christmas list because I still believed
in Santa mm-hmm and they actually caught
it
whoa I was really excited I love that -
mm-hmm
no that's so gross to have like a 30
year old toothbrush don't you think is
it grocers well yeah it's probably gross
more like is 180 functional would be a
relic yeah um I don't know I'm thinking
like one gift that I got as a kid or
younger or whatever that was like a huge
I mean I got a lot like my parents were
so good to me you know it's hard to just
like we don't play Little League like I
got the gear that I wanted like you know
I mean
they hooked me up and I would say the
best gift I ever got was from something
I bought for myself in high school when
I am is that that stupid catcher's
helmet why is it why would you call it
stupid it's like what top five one of my
most famous re proudly prized possession
in my life Yeah right I shouldn't call
this stupid I'm sorry it's really it's a
good present so I think to yourself yeah
I don't know I mean I feel like I'm
doing my parents dirty because I can't
like think of an epic gift that I'm sure
they got me sorry parents I don't think
you're watching it can you do the whoa
okay oh yeah at the same time yeah Wow
delete that from the internet I hate all
y'all
I hate all y'all cut the jenna julienne
podcast now on tick-tock if the dogs
were humans what kind of jobs would they
have I don't think Kermit could have a
job he's too unstable no mom he would
constantly lash out at his coworkers he
would show up late he would steal other
people's food he wouldn't be hygienic at
all Kermit our marvel would be a cop he
is definitely an old smug angry cop we
call him the fun police all the time
yeah he's just like these [ __ ] kids
doing it again
he just arresting kids yeah well I feel
like Peter just work in retail or
something should be like a hostess how
are you how are you can I get you a
table how many people are there yeah
she'd be like a really sprite waitress
or a host and then she would go in the
back all the time and just eat food and
then meet people and then eat food she
loves people in food and her boss
luckily enough adores her doesn't make
her take any of that food out of her own
paycheck you know she doesn't she gets
to eat on the house or go get you some
waters I need some french fries then
come back and then meet you
she really loves meeting
yeah the UPS guys she just who was the
postman or whatever yeah she was just
like all over him last night mm-hmm
bunny bunny he just wants to play for a
living
bunny would be like a kindergarten
teacher she likes dogs she likes people
but she mostly wants to have fun yeah
true or she'd be like a clown that goes
to kids birthday parties what'd I miss
unemployed well was this a cop peach is
a hostess at a restaurant mm-hmm and
bunny is a clown that goes to children's
parties yeah that's about it I hope that
answers your question okay all right now
let's go to individual questions okay
ready
Gina what is it like to move in settle
into a completely different city and
state how did you get accustomed mmm
like there's always I would say a year I
said a year to get yeah when I moved
from Rochester to Boston I was like you
know I'm going for college but like
after that even when I was done with
school and that really it really felt
like my home but I was like if I go
somewhere and I hate it I can always
move back you know it's a myth when I
moved to Los Angeles it was like I would
say a year or so to where I started
feeling like you know I thought my
little spots I found some friends or
people that I wanna hang out with yeah
but that first year is really hard and
it's easy to be like I hate it here
everything sucks I feel lost I don't
know anyone it's really hard to meet
people like it's easy to tap out in that
space and be like this isn't for me
yeah but I always at least try and push
myself to make it past that year mark
and if it doesn't feel like a fun place
to be in I would leave and for the most
part I mean it seems like I've made
decisions that have made me happy you
make good decisions well you know that I
told over them for a very long time I do
before I make them yes I do ordering
dinner every night is pure hell
I'm kidding I'm kidding what games are
you most excited to play highlights of
e3 for me um I would say I'm just so
stupidly excited to have Halo in my life
again that was such a big part of my
life growing up so I've never played I'm
excited I'm so excited to play all the
old games with you and we'll do all that
I honestly think we'll all do all the
campaign playthroughs together on stream
I'm excited I'm excited for the new halo
as well because they tease that at e3
super excited for cyberpunk but don't
really know much honestly about it I I
get that there's a ton of hype for it
and it's a cool thing and whatever but
I've seen like a couple of trailers and
now I'm just like ready to play it but I
have to wait a whole year so we'll see
the quarantined
Rainbow six quarantine looks cool it's
cool that they have the siege operators
in it I don't know I want to try VR it's
important no one else from e3 though
what's your favorite tik tok that one
where the guy is just wearing a bear
suit and then riding a motorcycle
well first he slides down the stairs in
this giant bear suit and then he's just
zooming on a [ __ ] motorcycle yeah my
favorite is the old woman I like
ironically like tick-tock but I was
telling Julian today like tick tock is
not like vine like you go on some of
those videos or tic TOCs that you think
i wonder what the comments look like and
they're all so sweet and positive
especially with the older people who are
on tick tock wholesome really they're
[ __ ] amazing
yeah totally there was that woman
talking about her makeup and how she
felt pretty that day and it was like oh
my god my heart and then you go to the
comments they're like you're killing it
you look so gray and your psyche oh my
god faith in human yeah well I also
think that the generation right now that
has tick tock and loves it like teeny
whatever you call that Generation Z
whatever they're all like hyper aware of
cyberbullying and like they don't
[ __ ] think that's cool and they don't
do it to each other they don't think
that just because I'm on the Internet
mean I need to be on an internet with
that existing well cuz they didn't grow
up with the and I'm having a hard time
saying this word non-dominant they
weren't anonymous on the online they've
always been themselves online do you
mean God where is a lot of us come from
an age on the internet where you can say
whatever you want and nobody knows that
it's your text box live whatever you
want to say like terrible awful [ __ ] yep
Chavez and whatever that generation when
you're on the Internet it's always you
and you are accountable for the things
that you say yeah they don't do that I
mean it still exists obviously yeah but
for that app to be that popular we're at
that age group and to see that age group
think that that's not [ __ ] cooler
acceptable is dope as hell for sure for
sure yeah I think that's an interesting
take you to update not really an update
just still training strain as much as I
can
between work and the dago's and
everything just keep on keepin on I'm
still training on a good week three
times on a bad week one time sometimes
zero times because I have you know
things to do and we like III was tough
couldn't really train during e3 but I
got my first stripe on my purple belt a
couple weeks ago thank you it's been
like exactly one year this month the
that I've had my purple go so it
trainees good I don't know really it
update plant update oh god please don't
ask ok weakening most of them has
actually been fine but we went to Hawaii
for a week and Chris and chin we're here
watching the dogs and I watered all the
plants before we left and I made sure
that everybody was not thirsty but I
wasn't because they were watching all
our dogs I didn't want to also be like
could you please just like watered this
one plant just like this much and like
do this yeah like no no like I said
don't do anything and then when we got
back from Hawaii we went and picked up
bunny and you know two weeks before then
is when we got
bunny and it was like the plants are
already suffering most of my plants have
done amazing like over the span of time
that it took me the even like mentally
be okay with like okay I can go water a
plant right now and not feel like I need
to make sure all the dogs are totally I
will say most of them are good but some
of the really small
unfortunately young ones the ones that
needed to be checked on every couple
days have just decided but I mean to die
like for the most part you go downstairs
to go in our bedroom and you see all the
array of plants they all look really
yeah and it was also it made me feel
really happy that so many of them were
like - yeah you got a new dog we're good
we're like I'm gonna drop a leaf on the
ground and buy you that I'm mad but I'm
still gonna stay alive in them really
pick that [ __ ] up [ __ ] some of them
were like I did like a day into it they
were like goodbye and then some of the
stink minutes nay plants were like well
we're told nothing happened especially
in that diamond which is gonna be that
dining room they're like there's not a
lot of light so they don't go through
water super fast they are chillin it's
like such a crazy room cuz you walk in
there and most of the times it's dark
it's like a dark room you go in you turn
on the light like didn't see all this
was in here and they're all just
fighting in the dark like just children
it's a very low light plant room but you
know when there's less light they're
taking in less water they're not growing
as fast obviously but yeah they're just
like fine for a while mm-hmm
where do you find music for your videos
I find music in a couple places the
first place I started looking with
SoundCloud now it's kind of not so much
that just because it's kind of like a
dining platform a little bit I still use
it but I think so I think there I kind
of think they're just they have it wrong
mmm I think Spotify is doing a lot of
good things I actually learned a lot
about this talking to Dylan
but it's interesting like SoundCloud
they kind of like pivoted what they you
know the way they were going and a lot
of people didn't really like it so they
moved to Spotify because Spotify was
fulfilling you need that
so I thought it wasn't but anyway
there's one page on Soundcloud I use
regular that's called chill hop it's a
great page it's run by a guy named bass
I met him over like video chat oh my
bunny many years ago that was when I was
working with bureaucratic Brandon so a
lot of times I'll find an artist that I
like whether I found them on Spotify or
elsewhere
Andrew apple pie inter apple pie is my
current favorite he's awesome he's I his
music really just speaks to me I love
making videos to his music I use them
for a lot of LMT and all of my videos
kind of recently yeah sometimes I'll
just you know just go through the little
platforms that you can sift through and
see what you find
and oftentimes if you're lucky you'll
find a harness that you just want to
keep working with I use the suggested
music in the YouTube music library true
if it ain't broke don't smash it I wish
I had more options for classical music
because I really do like putting that in
the back I love classical music in your
videos it's got a good vibe thank you
who's an unlikely person that's turned
out to be a fan of yours like a
celebrity there's someone who is I don't
know I wouldn't say a fan but supports
you or knows about you Ellen is that
friend that was a wild one yeah it's
funny Dillon Francis it's like the
nicest funniest sweetest person and you
know sometimes you're like you're Dillon
Francis
you're hanging out with like some
[ __ ] youtubers like low life low life
why you like us he's just a nice person
to be fair I don't know if he knew maybe
he did when we met him that's what I'm
saying I don't think he's a fan yeah an
unlikely person who's turned out to be
well I thought I would say turned out to
be a friend right yeah he's he's one of
my good friends really good guy I would
say though to answer that is Alessia
Cara that kind of oh my god when she
came up to us at the award show yeah I
couldn't believe that I was wild to me I
would not believe that all so sweet yeah
that was like five years ago I want to
say and dude five years ago and even
today but like especially early on like
you
people didn't really go up to me they
would go up to Jenna and be like hey I'm
a big fan love you and you'll be like I
love you too and you're like you're
youtubers or whatever and they'll be
nice to me but Alessia came up to me and
she was like hey Julian like I'm a fan
of you guys and was very nice and I was
like [ __ ]
did not expect that she's a wonderful
wonderful talented person
did you know Jenna had been following
when you met her we kind of talked about
this no no
in short no but then I soon learned she
kind of explained to me what everything
was I remember I had a conversation with
you were out you're like what do you do
I was like well I'm in school and I'm
doing this and there and you're like
well what are you doing school I'm like
well I write for the school paper and
you were like why yeah you're like why
do you make a youtube channel like
that's now I was like hmm interesting
and then like I didn't and then I did
yeah but it was hard to explain like I
was hey youtuber I work in radio and
newspaper like hello do you speak my
language no no no but it was that long
story short no not really
that was kind of it I mean there's a
couple that we missed stop turning them
us to face those nicer gonna go for a
little so one of the comments that was
like Julian turns Marvel's bed 180
degrees marbles impossible there was one
other question that escaped what was
your favorite podcasts oh man without it
without a guest there's a lot that I
like a lot that like you know we just
try stuff in you know throw ideas to a
wall and see what sticks in hindsight I
really liked our pizza party where all
of a sudden we were playing
hide-and-seek that was really really fun
I really like the you guessing songs
like you know there's really great
moments from podcasts that we're just
like let's see if this works like let's
see what this is
we're trying to sing songs on a key
without hearing them first like I think
in its entirety that podcast is
completely obnoxious just a lot of a lot
of them are just terrible podcasts but
it's like you get this moment you know
like the pizza party podcasts in its
entirety probably isn't that fun to
listen to but to watch you stand like a
gargoyle on a chair behind me you know
yeah for sure I think some of the like
unexpected like we're just we're trying
to see what if this is a fun idea or not
because you know when you come up with
ideas for something the only way to see
if it'll work is to just do it yeah
totally and like some honestly sometimes
neat ride stuff we're going yeah
first snake-oil was a surprisingly fun
one because I don't think we expected it
to be that good yeah and then I was like
candy but we're cops right that was
snake oil or the Segway off the Segway
Huff was pretty great
I don't think of some of the early early
ones oh the the one where we went
through the DSM with Brett I don't even
remember that we were in the dining room
at our old house like one of us was out
of focus yeah I think you're on I think
it was all three of us sitting there and
that's what a guest that is with a guest
that's true you cheat Billy Ray Sarah
Palin oh my god why do you remember that
I know we did it because people asked
for it and then it was terrible it's the
worst thing ever that was my music yeah
there's like you said there's been a lot
of unexpected good ones yeah the first
trivia where you discovered my inability
to oh my god just think we're
celebrities it was pretty funny it's
been a good time it's been a good time I
don't know what episode we're on over
like two 20 or 30 what number is this
look below and tell me what's insane to
me is that we've had guests on here and
we just smush him in between foursome
high-five over them kick him out looks
like the worst pod has to be on you just
like I have to look over here
and then over here and I'm just in the
middle and I feel so weird I mean I've
thought about it like we have I mean we
technically we could make it like oh we
have a camera angle and your camera
angle of me camera angle I guess the
live camera make people comfortable you
mean yeah like baby like maybe it's
across the round table each other make
it not a weird date we were sitting on
the same side of the booth as your
friend that's what this podcast is we're
on a date at a restaurant as friends and
we're there's like a table of four and
we're both taking up the two seats and
there's no one at those yeah yeah and
we're having conversations with our
imaginary friends who were in those two
seats mmm we kicked out of the
restaurant expelled then we got welcome
back they were back at the restaurant
but yeah I don't know I don't I kind of
think it if it ain't terribly broken
don't fix it if it's a little broken
just shadows put some dirt on it put
some ramen on it and paint over it yeah
be on our podcast at your own risk
anyways yeah we yeah do we make people
sign that we should if anything happens
to you to your well-being physical or
otherwise because I have a sorrowful oh
my god that did four questions I think
that's it oh thanks for your questions
yeah I think my favorite question was
the eat definitely eat eat eated or yote
eat he did he did I needed these I
needed those sponsor segues that you
needed okay needed permits ready cameras
ready to go eat some more of your hair
yeah you want to eat some hair bud thank
you guys for hanging out for another
podcast it was fun this was fun we
haven't done a Q&A in a long time thank
you
oh there she is there's bunny by the
time we have another Q&A a long time
thank you to Marissa for compiling the
questions thank you guys for sending in
the questions and we'll be we'll be back
next week and see you live on stream
thanks for hanging bye y'all
[Music]